[Music]
okay here's the thing I'm in Wales
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I've been flown to a farm in the middle
of the mountains to say speech about
keeping it real as a young film director
and when I arrived these two local girls
made me a list of things I should do
while I'm in Wales clear reenactment Dan
you made your list I'm only here for
tuna bit days but I'm gonna complete
everything on that list even the weird
[ __ ] I added two things to the nest
which are saying his future to have to
do in the next 30 minutes and then
making the film which I'm gonna do of
all of this I'm gonna be here now and
that's that's a very important thing but
at the same time I don't think that a
lot of us are sitting here and me saying
you know I am truly present creativity
is the ability to believe in your
perception enough so that you actually
create an art form out of it to share
with others around you it's your point
of contact it's a way of being able to
showcase the way you see the world to be
unique as beautiful and unique is
different and it's awesome here we're
all equally as awesome and I think that
for me why creativity is such a
beautiful space to explore okay there is
contains climb the highest mountain in
the UK get a tattoo that represents
whale surfing and land with jump of the
highest cliff and five go to a haunted
doll house at midnight it's far too
early in the morning when I start my
first mission to open in land wave which
is in an area called Snowden it's about
a seven hour drive I've never had the
opportunity to serve an inland where
super die
since the viewers look away I found dead
rats hanging out someone his house what
do you think they trying to say showers
are coming out of a chute take this one
this is the wave behind me I will suited
up ready to go it seems to be loads of
rules
[Music]
and in learned ways hopefully they asked
the girls to rewrite a list for me okay
that's good
the next section said to climb the
highest mountain in the UK that just
found out from a local isn't actually
the highest mountain in the UK but about
this waterfall nearby so I modified the
list slightly but off the path so I'm
gonna have to park my car somewhere hike
the rest of the way
[Music]
two K's in that direction
[Music]
why
[Music]
like confident enough yet I'll tell
people it's day two in Wales and is
pissing with rain we are going to go get
our tattoos now I decided to get a
singular whale I'm afraid Tim to get
another way also together
it's Wales we from South Africa and we'd
like to get a matching tattoos could we
get in today can we get this tattoo yeah
we are done we almost finished here and
then we gonna head is it north then we
heading east to go to a place called San
David just where we found out the big
curve champion
[ __ ] that's I did for whale
[Music]
last mission to a haunted doll house
which I'm not too happy about we're
gonna get there at midnight trying to
tell us not to come in behind me is the
hindrance spray and scary we interrupt
this blog to bring you
[Music]
back whales you have been incredible
thank you so much to the guys from the
do lectures and team do for inviting me
here I finished the list which is epic
thank you so much watching this vlog
where it's like a cool sign of line like
this is the last evening in Wales as the
embers in the sky start to die I say
goodbye
remember to stay not normal
[Music]